こんにちは
隣に住んでいるスミスですが
トリックオアトリートでご存知ですか
トリックオアトリートメント知らないです
よね
結論から言わせてもらいますと
月曜日の夕方に
子供たちにお菓子を渡していただきたいん
ですけれども私が渡すんですかああそう
ですもし可能であればいいんですけど私が
スミスさんの家に何時に行ったらいいです
か
ごめんなさい
子供たちがここに来ますこう
具体的に何時に来ますかそうですね他の方
の家に行ってから来ますので
具体的な時間がちょっとわからないんです
けれども
え近所を全体回るんですか
自治会長から許可もらえましたかもらい
ましたこちらです
特別火葬訪問許可書
仮装してくるんですかあそうです子供たち
が
スミスさんが
母国であるアメリカ合衆国で経験した行事
ハロウィン
以下
ご自身の子供たちに
体験させるべく
わかりましたしかしお菓子は何を用意し
たらいいかまだよくわからなくてですよね
ですよねなのでちょっと自分で用意してみ
ましたこちらを
渡していただけますと
幸いです何個渡したらいいでしょうかそれ
はお任せします
適当で大丈夫ですので
じゃあ3個にしますねありがとうござい
ますいやーしかし面白い行事ですね
仮装したり
他人にお菓子を渡したりですよねいや日本
にはコスプレが好きな人が多いと聞いた
ことあるんですけれどもあでも確かにい
ます大学時代に自分もちょっとはまりまし
たしかし佐藤さんにとって絶対迷惑だと
思いましたのでこちらも一応用意してみ
ましたとつまらないものですがもしよかっ
たら
東京マカロンですかいいのに
家族全員分入ってますので